elaine maxwell okay pilot said that uh
mad people were innocent yeah innocent
hold up hold up the real story about
yeah yeah and this isn't verified but
we're gonna say it anyway yeah it's the
casa amigo himself george clooney
yeah well she went down on him sucked
them off yeah sucked them over in a
bathroom in a bathroom sucked them off
allegedly you're sucked on a legend
she's the one a legend you know what i'm
saying
while george clooney's wife was busy
trying to save the world yeah yeah she's
the same i love why she's snitching for
what why is she snitching she's the one
who said that she did that
yeah she was bragging dude you wouldn't
brag you suck george clooney's dick i
know i would come on sock sock
bro she was out there sock suck yeah you
know what i mean
come on dick suck that's a little sweet
sweet [ __ ] just a sweet [ __ ] sucker well
one time for the king
you know what i mean son he's a hero dog
think who she would have been
victimizing getting his dick sucked she
was fine back in the day bro let me see
talk about it
huge tits
pretty face
class
literal class talk about it you know
what i mean like you would get your dick
sucked by in a bathroom by her too you
absolutely would there's not even a
question
yeah show shorty right there
no no no no
[ __ ] i mean we got better bro show her
more class this is not class
i like more class like when she has
clothes on and she's at like a ball
and maxwell classy yeah
yeah i'll search classy i'm sure this
exhibitor will have classy pictures yeah
not maxwell the artist [ __ ] read that
yeah what was this yeah didn't even know
that wasn't maxwell in artist anyway
me no him
you don't think he knows who maxwell is
no what's that song you guys always sing
dude
oh come on whatever yeah bro
done he's singing [ __ ] too oh did
maxwell poke his eye out or something i
think he'll fed him up
yeah no there's one guy that stabbed his
eye too
yeah but i wasn't maxwell who was that
who was uh goddamn he was like he was
like
[ __ ] like that right yeah music soul
child oh yeah music soul chop yeah yeah
it's kind of a maxwell
ah these people bro these people i'm
telling you dude these people these
people these people but with gizlane
right
can the first question just be how do
you pronounce your stupid [ __ ] name
dumb [ __ ]
just tell us how to pronounce your name
gulen
guilin yeah okay gilen class gilen when
she was just given that throat to george
clooney
right
can we really blame george clooney no
dude i'm telling you while she was
sucking his dick
she could have been victimizing some
young woman oh he was saving things he
saved mad young girls that whole time oh
she could have been out choosing her
next target target was him luckily of
age man wow this guy's a hero dude
low-key that guy is a hero [ __ ] no
that's a great point you're making right
dude george clooney hey he saved these
hoes bro you think she swallowed him up
yeah you gotta she loves kids
of course that was her favorite part
everything was brutal until that sperm
came out
and tried to put something in getting
pregnant she probably gave it to she was
like i got you the youngest thing
possible
[Applause]
you